the jurgen experience so what happened
you got accosted last night oh we're in
it this is just going yeah
yeah so um good to be here thank you
good to have you
good to have you yeah so we're here you
need booze
no i don't drink but i appreciate that
you want heroin heroin with good
yeah i'm still doing heroin that's
always like the hackiest joke
i don't drink but i want to buy heroin
it's like you always go like if someone
says they don't drink you go with
something
way more preposterous than drinking like
oh i'm sober right
the other one is uh well people say
quitter that's like a big one
it's a big one but um but no i
appreciate the offer though i mean this
cigar i might enjoy
a cigar sure yeah i'm on an empty
stomach it might make me
more jittery than i already am we'll
give it a little i'm a big settle in
yeah no you're not you're fine well what
did i tell this story okay
[Applause]
okay so yeah we're here in austin and i
got a ride
a lift to the hotel i'm staying downtown
and we were coming up
6th street which i don't know if you've
been down there it's changed a bit it's
like kind of
overrun with street folk homes yes
because there's quite a few uh of the
they call them unhoused that's the new
more politically correct term
sure i thought street people was good
but maybe i think street people's
i don't think they like that i don't
know if there's like a homeless
board talk about the vernacular that
they
appreciate yeah all right well unhoused
people that seem you know uh unwell
and they're kind of everywhere which
evidently they just passed a law
but it hasn't been well the law is only
about camping
okay i mean you can't stop people from
walking around
right so that there's always going to be
an issue and like uh
one of the clubs downtown is a vulcan
gas company
and uh that place is right caddy corner
to a homeless shelter so they're all
over the place in that area
that's where i think i was on seventh
right is that seventeen is on
sixth is it home yeah the shelter's on
seventh
yeah i think you're right okay well it's
in that area so we drove down the street
and the guy was
kind of saying yeah they've taken over
it's crazy it's scary be careful
whatever drivers
yeah so i'm like oh he was like a driver
driver but so i'm already
so i'm already like in my head and then
um
i asked the lady i was like is it safe
walking around here now it feels like
it's changed a bit and she was like just
avoid
sixth straight and i was like all right
got it and then
i was like i'm gonna go to the creek do
a spot texted rebecca and it's like an
eight minute walk so i was like i'll
walk there
now i'm a huge [ __ ] anxiety the whole
thing
although i have been doing mixed martial
arts but we can get to that later
um but so i was walking up the street
and i'm like all right so far
so good and then i started to get closer
and i saw these two guys
walking towards me and they seemed like
you know nerdu wells
just you know by the way they were
presenting themselves and then there was
a guy on a bicycle
like a bmx style bike who kind of was
with them and then rode ahead and kind
of did like a loop
behind me so then i was like all right
this feels
unsafe so i kind of just moved to the
street like off the sidewalk but still
right next to the sidewalk and then the
two guys as they pass were like look at
this [ __ ] this racist ass
[ __ ] moving into the street this
white guy this
and uh it seemed you were racist because
you moved
into the streets i think as i moved into
the street but that's not what i was
i wasn't like oh here come black guys
let me move up but they were walking
up the sidewalk so i just was moving so
i didn't have like a
and a moment where you had to zig or
zach exactly left to right
exactly so i stepped off the sidewalk
and they kind of called that out and
then
as they we passed each other i could
still hear him kind of like mumbling
they seemed like they were
[ __ ] up but um so they're still kind
of mumbling and then i came to the
intersection which is where i guess that
homeless shelter is and there was like
40 homeless people not like
sleeping in tents or on the sidewalk but
like fighting yelling
bottle smashing and i was just like i
don't feel like
walking through that that doesn't seem
great so then i look to the right with
sixth street where the lady was like
yeah stay off the sixth street and then
this is all in front of an empty parking
lot
so there's just nobody around it's dark
and i'm like if i go left i'm going up
dark street sidewalk so then i was like
i'll cross
sevens back over there and just start
walking back to my hotel so i have to
walk through whatever this scene is
and then as i was walking back that way
they were a little ways ahead of me and
for whatever reason they decided to
cross
back across the street and so we just
met
right there and then the guy's like you
wouldn't be following us would you and i
was like no no i'm just lost and i kind
of did like
i don't want any thing to do with you
guys and then the guy got like right up
into my face and was like you better be
[ __ ] lost
why don't you get law like something
whatever else i was in like panic mode
so i couldn't
and then there was one of those like
scooters you know those rental scooters
that are everywhere
yeah and he just gave that like a hard
kick and did like this thing and we were
kind of like
manager and an umpire just like right
there and i went no no i'm getting out
of here and i just kind of walked around
and then
swallowed all pride and just went full
full run
that's a good move all right thanks i
thought you're gonna call me no i might
appreciate it
i might have done the same thing well i
mean again it's like
it's a good move man you don't you don't
want to get into an altercation
if you can avoid it if you can avoid it
by running like the swallow the pride
thing like wouldn't
like what are you gonna do just get
attacked or what do you do fight
when you can if you can not fight by
running you should definitely run like
you talk to any martial arts instructor
they will always tell you that
if you can get away a smart one will
tell you get away a dumb one will say
first rule you gotta kick him in the
knee then you gotta [ __ ] poke him in
the eye like the three stooges
you know get the [ __ ] out of there man
get out of there yeah so i've done
a little bit of mma training the last
couple years and like that's the basic
idea obviously at whatever level if you
want to say
level the idea is to use whatever skills
to get out of harm's way i'm not looking
to inflict
damage on people sometimes it's just
people just want to [ __ ] with you
so these guys probably just wanted to
[ __ ] with you and make you feel
uncomfortable and make you scared
because if they wanted to do something
they probably would have done something
right yeah that's how i felt and i also
i literally consciously thought
me running gives them what they want
they get a nice like that's right [ __ ]
and i'm fine with that
i'm 39 years old i'm not looking to
prove anything to anybody
and then rebecca was like texted who
runs the creek and was like i could send
security and i was like
i'll take it as a sign i'll see you
tomorrow night i'll take a look they
have solid security at the creek though
they have some big-ass giant dudes oh
really yeah some solid dudes oh good to
know well tonight i'm gonna take a lift
i'm good with
walking but it was scary but i felt good
because
i'll come get you tonight i'll pick you
up all right i'll take it we'll talk
i appreciate it well i i felt good
because when i got back i was like
i didn't sit there going you're a [ __ ]
you piece of [ __ ]
and nor was i like panicking i was just
like all right that was crazy
yeah it's not good you you're you're
always better off just
swallowing pride it's hard to do but
it's so important
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience
on spotify you can listen to the jre in
the background by using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode of the joe rogan experience